so Andrew T and Greta have went at it on
Twitter but this is Andrew Tate's final
response
gases
[Music]
obviously a stranger to online
controversy is not something I often do
but now
the mainstream press is commenting on
the fact that
I was informing Greta that my very
extensive car collection with internal
combustion engines which run on dead
dinosaurs have an enormous emission
profile
and she replied by telling me her own
email address
Greta's email address is I have small
dick energy isn't that um body shaming
to guys with small dicks you know what
it is and to be fair I never liked when
people made fun of that because I think
it must be I don't make fun of fat
chicks but a fat chick can get skinny or
get in shape it's something out of your
car like that is like making fun of
somebody for being ugly or you know yeah
you gotta be having a mental disorder
you're having a mental disorder like
yeah you know having buck teeth or like
it is funny don't make fun of a man for
the size of his penis like that's really
[ __ ] mean like because that is a big
part of a man's identity whether women
like it or not and they like to make fun
of men for that being part of their
identity while women spend all day on
makeup and hair and eyelashes and making
sure butt implants and stuff and then
they'll make fun of a man for caring
about the size of his penis like you
know what yeah I know for the people
that always say like don't use the word
you know the word gay because it's
hurtful you know body positivity and
then they go off and they just do it to
a different demographic yeah they're
Hypocrites absolutely right and I and I
think it's really mean and so Greta
doing that you know talks to talk about
being bullied oh she's been so bullied
and yet she is saying something really
shitty and even if she thinks oh I'm
just saying it to him anybody that has a
small penis is gonna hear that and feel
bad about themselves I'm sorry and it's
just shitty it's not cool and it's like
what what do they really mean by small
dick energy because like they also talk
like I said we they don't talk about
gender roles you know they don't believe
in masculinity or nothing so like what
is your penis size have to do with
anything oh because they say that guys
with small penises they go out and they
drive fast cars and they they do all
this stuff to try they have big trucks
and big giant wheels to try to make up
for the fact that they've got a small
wiener like shut up like just shut up
that judgment on men it's enough and
it's all by women who do nothing but
complain about how they're judged make
sure you're speaking into the microphone
I am speaking into the microphone it is
just as far from my voice like this and
then well I'm an animated person you
know what get over it give me five
[ __ ] microphones if that's what it's
gonna take would that be your own email
strange how could that be I don't want
to assume her gender it's 50 50. but
it is what it is
I'm not actually mad at Greta
please bring me pizza and uh make sure
that these boxes are not recycled
I can't believe that people genuinely
think that he got caught because of a
pizza box oh yeah no no where where what
room is he in take a wild guess you
watch you watch him what we're missing
where would you say this room is it
looks like an office it's the War Room
he's in Armenia anyone that watches him
knows that is unique this unique wooden
room is the War Room strictly in Romania
unless he just magically got a whole
duplicate room built in Dubai idiots and
whenever you go into a country is there
not a process of getting into that
country if you're fluent on a jet into
an airport where they can easily track
them he saw the most famous guy ever if
he goes anywhere there's like a million
pictures taken he's still in generally
in one of two places
they say they always they do this with
so much stuff though they just make up
random [ __ ] I'm like like what are
you lying about pizza boxes for why is
that on the news that he's getting
caught for a pizza box and then people I
forgot that part about it it's almost
like a test to see how stupid people are
all right let's remember that Greta
thundberg has a bunch of 10 year old
followers too no she has like grown she
has grown followers and sadly too right
because she doesn't she doesn't realize
she
rammed she realized she was
just sat her down and convinced her
to try and convince you
to beg your government
to tax you into poverty to stop the Sun
from being hot
and then because I called her out on it
the global Matrix got this bot Farm
to like and retweet and all this bot
commenting to try and pretend her oh
yeah there's no I was thinking that same
[ __ ] there is no way she ratioed him by
10 times where she got like 300 million
views on her tweet and three million
likes and he only got 300 000. that's
such a trash come on she has a small
dick in her own email address
somehow teaches me illness
welcome to a new episode of the clown
but now I know at least
that Greta with a little hate-filled
face
bitter somewhere but that's pretty good
in the cold I miss this guy me too we
miss you top gee use my Tweets we're
just gonna make my Twitter account far
more fun into attorney what do you guys
think on this whole situation the whole
interaction between Tate and Greta has
absolutely exploded on the internet
comment your thoughts below I think it's
a whole lot of [ __ ] I think the
Matrix is coming after him hard over
ridiculous claims like this this sex
trafficking thing like it is it is such
a like it's crazy that this is what we
don't know that okay let's be fair let's
be fair we are making assumptions based
on our impression our knowledge of him
other people are making assumptions
based on their Impressions and knowledge
right now so for starters what most
people think of sex trafficking is like
throwing people into a van and smuggling
them to a country and then hiding them
in a basement using them so obviously
Tate's not doing that that is all like
that's out of the picture people like
are starting to understand that so now
we're getting into like the more you
know specifics of what sex trafficking
means so one of the things is like love
coercing or love manipulation where you
get someone to fall in love with you and
then you use them for work so now that's
what they're saying he did because in
one of his old programs that's what he
said he did and I'm just like if you're
gonna manage a bunch of only fans girls
and live with them I don't know I don't
even say they're as much of a problem
they might catch feelings and that
doesn't make it that doesn't seem that
that's illegal those girls were all
being paid well right well they're also
become more loyal employees like the
thing is yeah they're getting paid well
and it's like you're you're going after
this system for sex trafficking so hard
when you get screwed up the bum royally
by the company you work for you don't
even make point one percent of the money
you bring in you make nothing and the
real sex traffickers are still out there
like the real ones I'm not even gonna
say the names you all you all know and
there's nothing being done about that so
that is just definitive proof that this
isn't about him maybe he did make them
fall in love with him and it was all
just to get them to work for him Hey
listen people fall in love you can't
help it okay I mean I I guys fell in
love girls fell in love unrequited love
is part of is part of life so if that is
the case then yes I agree with you and I
also I do not think he did this I do not
I do my gut tells me he's innocent but I
also don't want to be a fool and I want
to you know we don't have the facts it's
very easy to pass judgment I'm sitting
here I'm sitting here you know 10 000
miles away without any direct knowledge
you know we're not we haven't been there
we're not there for it you're an agent
no I'm not an agent I'm realistic and I
like to have facts before I pass
judgment yeah there are no facts that's
the funny thing again right there have
been no facts that have come out and
you're absolutely right and I've been
looking for facts and they're not there
so again I do think he's innocent but
I'm not you know we can't be sure of
anything and then the other thing that's
funny is that they're not bringing up
the money laundering like the the pizza
money launderer like yeah he's totally
money money laundering in a country with
two percent tax all you have to do is
say that he's a money launderer and a
second Africa for people to believe it
so they're just gonna throw anything at
the wall and see what sticks as far as
he's concerned because he's exactly
extremely inconvenient human being right
now he is just waking up people all over
the place and then you've got Elon Musk
being so annoying and letting Free
Speech Reign oh they're [ __ ]
themselves it's it's really problematic
for the the powers that be oh yeah 100
and then I think that this year is going
to be a little bit more calm not like
more calm it's going to be kind of calm
and then the next year 20 20 24 is going
to be just like insane with the new
election we're gonna have people fist
fighting in the street over a [ __ ]
loaf of bread with the way the economy
is where things are going it's like a
food shortage so don't expect calm thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe follow me on Instagram
follow me on Instagram no no just nobody
cares about nobody cares
gone
[Music]
[Music]